they're seen as the muscle of the
russian military
feared for their brutality on the
battlefield
soldiers from chechnya fighting for
president vladimir putin in ukraine
the chechens are believed to be in the
thick of a fighting here in what's left
of mario pole
they've released this footage they say
is from inside the city
it shows them going house to house and
firing on residential buildings
they're loyal to this man ramzan
khadirov
the pro-kremlin president of the chechen
republic who calls himself putin's foot
soldier
i'd like to give some advice to the
current president of ukraine voladimir
zelensky before he becomes the former
president of ukraine
you should hurry up and call our
president the commander-in-chief
vladimir putin and ask for his
forgiveness
during the second chechen war khadirov
and his militia helped moscow defeat
separatist rebels and bring chechnya
back under russian control
it was a brutal war that left for
capital grozny in ruins
scenes similar to the destruction seen
today in ukraine
khadirov claims tens of thousands of his
men are fighting in ukraine
whatever their true number they're seen
as a potent psychological weapon for
vladimir putin but analysts suggest they
might actually be more hype than help
this footage filmed by the ukrainian
military on the outskirts of kiev claims
to show what's left of a chechen column
after an ambush
burnt out armor litters the road
but khadirov denies his forces suffered
any setback
some say that many of our fighters were
killed
we have not sustained a single loss not
a single soldier has been wounded not a
single soldier scratched not a single
person has even caught a cold
uh
a fierce fire fight in a village
northeast of kiev
this video was posted on social media by
a ukrainian volunteer unit
it's believed fighters from chechnya are
in its ranks fighting for the government
in kiev and against ramzan khadirov
chechens on both sides of a front line
in a war within a war
for more on this aspect i'm now joined
by miriam hess she's a research fellow
as the german council on foreign
relations who's written extensively on
chechnya and it's militias now ramzan
khedira calling for the storming of kiev
just as russia announces uh it is
scaling back its forces in that area is
he acting outside of the kremlin's
authority
well first of all i think we have to
understand uh kaididov's role really in
the putin's power structure and this is
more
that khadirov is really the only person
or one of the persons that is only loyal
to putin himself right so i think this
narrative of him acting outside of
putin's command is something
i'm highly skeptical about i think um
this maneuver of him really like trying
to emphasize this war narrative of being
ready to storm and um like to fight kiev
is something which is just like playing
into the narrative of him um trying to
instrumentalize um the stereotype of the
chechen war proven combat experience
fighter again so i'm highly skeptical
about him really acting outside of
putin's command i rather think that he
is um
trying to add some fight experienced
narrative again to the conflict as
russia is now like
allegedly retrieving his troops from
kiev
now in our report we mentioned that a
war within a war tell us more about this
very complex role that chechens and
church and fighters are playing in
ukraine
yes um i think um
chechens living in exile for example in
europe and then trying to fight russia
and some kind of international
battlefields is something that is not
new it is not new now and we also
witnessed that not like recently in
syria
so it is really chechens now fighting on
the ukrainian side is a phenomenon that
is really corresponding to um the
history of like experiencing two of
having experienced two wars and
they're now trying to um like really
extend and continue their fight against
the russian um system and or russian
regime because now the fight the second
chechen war for example was initiated by
putin and he is still of course the
leader and what makes the cheddar
narrative on the ukrainian side now so
so more like conscious or aware for us
is or prominent for us is that the war
now is a war between ukraine and russia
and in syria for example the chechens
were also very prominent um
and very present but because this war
was like more under the narrative of
some kind of like jihad um we
really
not like took it as it was um meaning
that the chechens fighting on the
ukrainian side are really trying to
continue the battle against
russia on the
russian side as you said uh already
there are the cardiology meaning this
private military militia um from
kaidirov fighting on the
russian side and really trying to like
be part of some kind of psychological
warfare and to frighten ukrainians into
like really surrendering it's
interesting that you mentioned that the
frightening the ukrainians khadirov's
chechen fighters have a fearsome
reputation um is it justified
well um
it is hard to say that it's justified
because if we think about um the the
history of chechnya there's not really
like a situation in which the chechens
on russian side could have proven
themselves to be that combat experienced
right because the chatrooms that are
fighting now on the russian side are
rather young and the war is over not
only for two years but a little longer
so there's not really like there's no
proof that they are really that quiet
and combat experience it is rather um
yeah they're rather like really trained
to secure protest and to like really
secure any kind of political position
opposition within chechner but it is
really hard to like say okay so this
those are the guys within ukraine we
should really be afraid of because
there's no like
no recent his uh example where we could
have really like
seen their compact experience
miriam has them
the german council on foreign relations
thank you very much for joining us
russia's pledge to reduce military
operations around the ukrainian capital
kiev has been met with skepticism by the
united states and ukraine they say
moscow is just repositioning troops and
not withdrawing over in ukraine's
eastern region of donetsk held by moscow
backed rebels heavy shelling damaged
apartments and in urban as a suburb of
keefe russian forces have been pushed
back
leaving ruins behind
while russia's pledged to reduce its
operations around two ukrainian cities
came after peace talks between russian
and ukrainian delegations in istanbul
ukraine has proposed that it is willing
to become permanently neutral but says
it requires security guarantees from a
group of nations
another round of peace talks but this
time with first signs of progress
as ukraine opens up to discuss adopting
a neutral status russia promised to
scale down operations
the russian defense ministry has made
the important decision to decrease
military activity several fold in the
direction of kiev and chernahiv to
increase mutual trust and create the
necessary conditions for further
negotiations
negotiations that will be needed to
increase trust but in action and not in
words ukraine's president stressed
yes we can say that the signals we hear
from the talks are positive
but these signals can't silence the
explosions of russian shells
of course we see all of the risks
and of course we don't see grounds to
trust the words coming from
representatives of the country that
continues trying to destroy us
russia's announcement was also met with
skepticism in washington
but i think we should be clear-eyed
about the reality of what's happening on
the ground and no one should be fooled
by russia's announcements we believe any
movement of forces from around keeve is
a redeployment and not a withdrawal
and the world should be prepared for a
major offensive against other areas of
ukraine
offensives that in the future should be
stopped by other countries acting as
security guarantors
an idea that kiev proposed in exchange
for neutrality and in place of nato
membership
as peace talks gain momentum there is
now also another possibility on the
horizon
a high level meeting between both
presidents
now let's bring in dw correspondent
matthias berlinger he is in kiev
matthias russia says it will drastically
reduce its military activity near
chenehiv in the north and the capital
o'keefe what's your assessment from the
situation on the ground then
well from what we're hearing and i mean
what we're hearing with the thunder
we're hearing in the air the shelling
that we can hear even here from the city
center of kiev uh fighting has not uh
relented it has if anything intensified
of course we cannot
hear who has fired which rounds and we
also know that there has been offense an
offensive by the ukrainian army but the
fighting is at this moment going on and
what we have been hearing from
officials in this
suburb of kiev european that the
ukrainian army claims to have
re-conquered is that the place is still
regularly shelled by the russian army on
the other hand it's also not clear what
mean what it means to reduce
fighting it we know what it means to
uh
halt fighting but what
how how do we measure a reduction in
fighting um it's
it's never
at the same intensity level anyway so um
there are many questions about that and
there is also deep distrust here not
only from officials but also in the
population um what as far as this
announcement is concerned russia has
previously uh
withdrawn or said it would withdraw uh
withdraw its troops and then attacked
afterwards so
we have to see what happens on the
ground until we can make an assessment
of that
but here's there have also been reports
about intensified shelling in eastern
ukraine what more can you tell us about
that
yeah we've heard these reports and
they're in line with what russia has
said russia has said at the same time it
would um
ease
its attack here on the capital of kiev
and concentrate on what they call the
liberation of donbass which means that
they would uh
most probably try to conquer as much
territory as possible of these two
districts luhansk and donetsk part of
which uh was controlled by the
self-proclaimed republics that russia
has recognized in the run-up to this war
so um
an intense
intensified fighting in that region
would be totally in line with what
russia has said
dw correspondent matthias berlinger
there talking to us from kiev thank you
matthias
and our next guest is aglaia snetkoff
she's a writer and the author of
russia's security policy under putin
russia claims it will reduce its
military activity western governments
say they have to see it to believe it
are you seeing it and are you believing
it
so i think following the announcements
um
that the russians would
cut down on their shelling of kiev and
chennai at the moment we're not seeing
that as your correspondent suggested
there has been intensified shelling of
both cities overnight
um if we're looking at what's happening
on the ground there has been some
withdrawal of russian troops from
outside keefe
but there hasn't been major movements of
troops
so do you think it's rather
it's a with it's rather a regrouping uh
than than a a withdrawal
so i think the russians will move
towards fighting sort of a war and
attrition probably
closer to the
and they're still hoping once they have
captured mariopol to create a land
corridor from crimea going all the way
to dumbass that will be the focus from
now on i would suggest
now this is one of the largest armies in
the world the russian the russian army
why have they been unable to meet their
military objectives so far
so in some ways we actually have been
all very confused about what the
military objectives were so it is the
largest army they have in theory
reformed the army after the failure of
the georgia 2008 war but it seems that
the initial assumptions of a quick
operation in ukraine has failed they
were overstretched they tried to do it
from three fronts
the logistics have been fairly poor
there is a strong lack of coordination
we still have no idea who's actually
directing the military operation
and you know there's poor morale on the
ground effectively they have also
come up against very great um ukrainian
resistance so we mustn't underestimate
the ukrainian resistance but also sort
of the political failures of choosing
this campaign
now the hope of a quick victory has long
been dashed what other options might
putin be considering right now
i think at this point they will be
focusing on dumbass i think the war of
attrition
trying to grind the ukrainian forces
down in the east
mariopo continues to be the focus and as
i said the creation of sort of that land
corridor we will continue seeing um
shelling of other areas in ukraine but i
would assume at least for now the focus
on is on eastern ukraine however that
does not mean that the russian
operations won't shift in the future
atlas netcup there an expert on russian
foreign and security policy thank you
very much
thank you
germany's government is activating an
early warning plan to prepare for
possible shortages of gas deliveries
from russia
economy minister robert harbeck says a
crisis team is being established to
monitor gas supplies this follows
moscow's demand for payment in rubles
which germany and many other importers
have rejected harbic who's with the
environmentalist green party in
germany's government also urged industry
and households to conserve energy
we are
in a situation where i have to say
clearly that every kilowatt hour of
energy saved helps
and that is why i would like to combine
the triggering of the early warning
level for gas supplies with the appeal
for help to companies and private
consumers
you are helping germany you are helping
ukraine when you reduce your use of gas
or energy in general
einstein
now our political correspondent uh jared
reed is following this story and joins
us now jared what is this early warning
plan and what does it mean that they've
activated it
right so gerhard this is a level one of
a three level response
and basically what this early warning
level means is that a crisis team is
going to be meeting every day they will
be made up of representatives from
robert harbeck's industry who we just
heard from in that sound bite but also
service providers of energy
representatives of the regions in
germany they're going to be meeting
every day and monitoring the situation
closely and i guess working out
their responses to the next two levels
which are the alarm level and then
eventually level 3
the
emergency level and as you mentioned
this is in response i guess to a demand
from vladimir putin that gas be paid for
going forward in rubles this is
something that the g7 group of nations
which is led by germany at the moment
has rejected and in response the kremlin
is due to announce on thursday uh a set
of rules for how it expects
its energy like gas to be paid for uh
going forward so what has been set up
today i guess is a precautionary
response
in response to this push by the kremlin
because as countries like germany which
are trying to reduce their energy
reliance on russia they're not quite
there yet they need to work out what
they will do in a more formal way if
russia does decide to stop supply
now germany has repeatedly said it would
not stop importing energy from russia
due to its dependence
but how concerned is berlin right now
that moscow may shut off its gas
supplies
well one of the underlying messages from
corbett harbeck is that it's not in a
kind of panic stations mode yet there is
enough gas for industry and consumers
and he kind of highlighted that what has
been done today is a more precautionary
sense they are waiting though to see
what these new rules are uh that are
going to be unveiled on thursday uh by
moscow uh robert harbeck said that as of
now russia is fulfilling its contractual
obligations
germany it must be stressed can't
immediately do without russian gas but
it is working towards that it's a goal
though that's going to take a few years
to achieve but the government is saying
there is no risk of immediate gas
shortage
dws jared reed there thank you very much
jared
you